[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are going to be talking about
interesting things that happen around
Alex HN Alex thanks so much for coming
onto the show yeah yeah really
appreciate having you again Alex and I
first met what was the group called
again interesting intelligent crazy
people intelligent crazy people is the
group and who's the starter of diovan
tars Joshua van van tire van [ __ ]
shout-out to Joshua because that groups
very interesting intelligent crazy
people there's a lot of smart people in
that group I we were blessed to be
introduced to Alex and then we
interviewed you as episode number 86 I
think in Boston and that was a lot of
fun and when he's a Somerville yo
Somerville which is in the Boston and
where I was born
also in some Raziel shout out to the
Boston area lot lots of smart people in
Boston boston's like the East Coast
Silicon Valley to me it was wait it was
past times
it still is kind of depending on how you
define it okay so I love the
conversation with Alex and we're gonna
dive into these interesting things that
happen around Alex we have a lot of
really good topics Alex's the number one
question asker on Quora over 50,000
questions asked and even still today
you're posting questions tons of
questions on to facebook and asking
people about their thoughts on things
and it's been awesome to have see what
people aren't answering to these really
awesome questions that you asked okay so
you we have we have a list of things
that we want to talk about so I want to
ask you about being a generalist versus
being a specialist
all right what do you think there are
many pressures for a specialization
simply because specialists are easy to
train generalists are often generalists
in their own unique and special way
which makes it hard for them to converge
on similar scene so maybe the maid skips
conversion similar important points I
think being a journalist requires like
it's like less guidance and also the
types of scene that you're a generalist
over are not exactly well-defined a lot
of generalists might start off by
reading say Britannica or in the cyclope
Diaz by those even those encyclopedias
are very biased in their coverage of
topics over the coverage of what's
important which is why I like people
often tend to neglect say topics that
are of soup considerable importance to
do daily daily life and too sometimes
you notice that even the smartest people
are really good just optimizing and
knowing what's really important in the
day-to-day life interactions such
include social media and social media is
totally the venue where encyclopedias
socket and where say a good generalist
should have knowledge over but the
generals in the past even people at
Freeman Thyssen do not have much
knowledge over social media or at least
important parts of social media now for
it so much be a good generalists we have
to realize that time our time and the
universe is just so freaking short that
we live that we have to focus in on what
locally relevant ourselves iein lawful
locally relevant to ourselves but what
they label as a recurring relevance
basically scenes that are continually
reverence all the time for example a lot
of human interaction stuff also it's
like the entire growth of the Internet
is something that also that it's also
something where people's knowledge it's
just it's just very hard to cover in
traditional encyclopedias like Wikipedia
and oftentimes people can over learn
drama that occurs behind them but it's
still important to have to Ethan's like
which one which scenes of a certain
parent for example a lot of people say
that I'm good at knowing lots of people
and even though it's not the best metric
of things you know it's at least
sometimes a more robust that trick when
you're lost and when sometimes certain
people especially say teal fellows seem
to create create bubbles of
interestingness also if after eight then
say others and say traditional more
well-defined venues of knowledge
creation it seems like a see here
another scene about knowledge and
knowledge representation is hmm
like I know a lot some people are trying
to represent knowledge just graph these
days and or nodes or what or also times
like what got what's on in on people's
heads and what people and also like
knowledge that one is likely procedural
knowledge knowledge that is likely when
it's like you to remember over time and
maybe acknowledge that sticks on and
what that might one may forget over time
and also it's important to note that
pursuing knowledge for the sake of
knowledge is not all the best pursuit
you also have to have like in mind some
idea of how once if it's a knowledge in
youth but sometimes like it's like I
noticed that especially in the Bay Area
how a lot of people are good at figuring
out when you learn only one is needed
and then know when to garbage Department
garbage collects or forgets it when it's
not sometimes people have like even
really smart people don't have the best
memory they just forget Alice as quickly
as they learn it but at least have the
intelligence you know when you forget
the problem of school because of the
front loads also learning and the
beginning and that's where a lot of
people send you forget much of it though
some people tend to not forget as much
we can create the illusion of progress
so a lot of people I talk with also
create I also like Romeo Stevens they
they they question themselves what
exactly doesn't mean to maintain program
to actually have proper overtime I think
a lot of people have an illusion of a
continued trajection of progress when in
reality a lot of them actually losing
relevance over time I think for some
people the most important problem is the
problem staying relevant if you do not
stay relevant then you are basically
going to become noise it's when you're
older years and this is why we have the
loneliness epidemics you
and so the problem one of the problems
are most interested in is basically
figuring out how to properly know what
you know in order to stay relevant so
that one can be properly insulated
against the low in this epidemic that's
the low bar and the higher bar says to
shape the world in the way you want to
basically as Joseph Elia once tweeted or
from mark Andreas and if you really know
what you want to do the world and
executed well the world shapes itself
around you more more so than you then
you can think so in order to do that you
need to have proper epidemics and feed
loops because you do not want to have
magical thinking or delusions and you
have to very very quickly have your
loops of where of say where you're over
over optimizing in the wrong way or over
over learning in the wrong direction
which a lot of you are prone to doing
especially if they are prone to valuing
themselves based on how much they look
they know amazing stream of
consciousness ok so the child is born
and there is only a certain amount of
neural real estate yeah yeah and so and
it shrinks over time and if the ability
to parse information if we don't have a
very high signal-to-noise parsing
ability we
you become irrelevant yeah yeah all the
people are overtaking by Bab what Romeo
Stevens calls fabulous oftentimes it's
drama or like they don't know how to
think for himself they're overly sleepy
others and because they're scared of
disappointing other people when they
don't even model other people as
sometimes people might get a little bit
locally upset that say you didn't reply
to their email but over the long run in
general it doesn't matter that much as
long as you did not cross through I
should have royally picking them off in
a memorable way oftentimes when you look
when you interact with some of the
highest output people would you notice
with them is that they have hundreds of
emails per day the and often obscene
honestly responsive though if you know
them well enough you know how to reach
out to them if if during times that you
really really need to reach out to them
and often times how do you interact and
how do you get to know these super high
effect people all the time the only
solutions to basically grow up with them
still why like people who attend elite
schools like Stanford still often that
being an early intervention life because
they catch on to out seeing people when
they're back when they're young in the
formal years and have a cure the entire
impetus out of history of these people
in the affirmative
early years I'm a lot of times with
older people with happens o to people is
that they still have knowledge but they
don't remember how they learned it and
they like to have abstractions but
sometimes they're their abstractions are
learned in the idiosyncratic way and
when they lose the input history of the
idiosyncratic way in which you learned
it it's almost like a foreign language
new people so then even though so then
even after that long after the food
intelligence with the client it seems
like they're super smart because you're
a fractions are still impossible for
people to understand but but they're but
they've kind of become none your
plastic-like
output the only machines mm-hmm to it
exactly okay let's let's
let's hit this I found what you said
really fascinating about when you grow
up with someone you know the collection
of that worry you know basically awful
it's like this a lot of really effective
people like super smart people they
don't they they learn at the rate they
learn do things at what's fastest rate
wait for them but it explains how they
got to the process takes time away from
continually doing this is why the not
best explainer example one person
Kulkarni and she divides people into
three categories called nerd philosopher
and resourceful I would add and pass
there but that's another story by the
last week I would add and past but
that's enough story impact yes yeah or
accordant you're I'm basically and what
are the differences so nerds are
basically like people like dodge or Nick
hammer odda who basically or Kevin crock
who basically like learn [ __ ] loads and
they do things in their own way
sometimes they don't necessarily they
aren't necessarily the best in school
oftentimes hackers and tinkerers
and creative engineers they like to do
things their own ways and process input
input input and outcome of their own
ways indeed interesting practical ways
and up it in a way that so that aren't
aren't the most possible to other people
aren't all the times that they don't
have huge motivation parse it in the
same language is a little people and if
you say if you grew up with them or live
with them in their formative earlier
influence we're growing up you you have
an idea of what made them become what
they are and even if you don't pick up
on everything they do you you pick up on
enough of it you could get a sense of
why they are say so freaking effective
that being massive alkyd machines okay
something that you said earlier you were
making this interesting distinction
between a specialist and a generalist
but specifically with especially a
specialists are often than there it's um
yes and here's something because you
were you were breaking downs categories
I thought this is maybe an interesting
way to relate to it
a specialist is easier to train so we're
spending more time with training
people to become specialists but with
with with my self-made specialists to
with yes and then with with generalists
you said sometimes people just start oh
yeah do you train key which we scheduled
and everything also a distinction that
is more complicated than it than it
looks now I'll have your parts done
later I look time sometimes schools
especially with people who have tried to
employ seen better in all the subjects
and it kind of turns off a lot of these
nerds have mentioned who gets what you
just want to become viciously good at
what they want to be viciously good at
and because time is so limited we should
not prevent them their words from a
recognizing that they're really good at
being what they're good at because it is
hey are we gonna land and to interface
with super good journalists the
journalists will will have an idea of
how true probably was probably happily
and if you feed into these specialists
so the specials can continue being
awesome okay so let's talk about the
organization of knowledge because we
were talking about organizing a wave
that specialists can par super well and
and when they want to so there's this
limited amount of time that we have to
live there's this limited amount of
neural real estate how do you figure out
now it's different for every person
that's right every person would
ridiculously good at what you're
ridiculous I think we're not not so good
at
okay so expand on that a little bit more
because in the future people everyone
say that the future is like where
uniqueness matters more and where you
want to be done replaceable that's how
to stay relevant in the long run though
of course you also want people to
understand you well enough so that they
can interface with you but if any of you
are super unique anyways it's just hard
to boot remain with you anyways but the
Pope but the point is let's see how did
you stay relevant for my part for
example I am a journalist and I just
notice that almost no one else is a
journalist in the same way that I am I'm
a generalist too probably in different
ways how would you classify yourself as
a general
for example I know that internet really
well I grew up on the Internet
I grew up also grew up with conflicting
desires that were over whether or not
the internet with like waste of time
over with a school at least a time of
course ultimately there's a comment on
Facebook that Choucha grande posted and
then someone replied about about about
say extracurricular activities being
Maurice from school or someone's to
mention that and then I just said the
injured all the time I waste on the
intern was more useful in school and now
I see why I said the way way I said of
course a software development named love
the commented or wasted time I've spent
on the internet was more important than
school yes yes yes and because I'm like
for the language and math and science
and history oh look at school people a
lot of unschooled people like this there
are a lot of unschooled people now who
actually basically learned everything
even self-motivated with someone at
school I don't know about how self what
percent of population what percent of
population can actually unschool beyond
school himself I mean I grew up reading
exactly cousin Alex for fun so I'm the
type of person who is totally fine
who would I think is most likely to
thrive in a school environment it's
possible that there are other people who
doesn't need to be taught in order to
but how did you learn to read I just I
forgot but I did not think of school I
mean I I mean I just read encyclopedias
and medical journals are fun and I'll
see you know the internet I grew up on
the internet as well and growing up as
an Internet like it has exposed you so
much a material that you can get to be
for fun and this and you just pick up so
much so much so many um
way to communicate through that anyways
and I'm a more organic way sometimes I
also grew up on online forums and
they're oftentimes more organic less
policy if you have more of the context
behind them and it's important to have
context energy state in order to
communicate in proper ways a lot of
academic tension you community wave so
we're all context is removed and then
what happens that you have let's say a
lot of papers where we're all kinds of
removed and often people just hate
reading we didn't read all the stacks
and stacks of paper so though academic
um though of course um academic reviews
that some racing's are still great
okay so then every person has a
different way that they will find what
they love doing and that yeah we'll find
how to maximize the way that they parse
information to get the most relevant
information yeah the most relevant in
the hierarchy of yeah yeah okay that's
that's awesome so then now how does
persistent influence work with it
there's one so I know our influencer
asleep in the media or popular teacher
sauce and they might frequently might
attract attention because they produce
content that people want to see you or
me that could it's time to make people
feel good in themselves
lots of times scenes that produce large
amounts of page views
fall off over time I mean I I was there
I was there to watch much of course
history I've seen my mini court of power
users and I've seen a lot of them have
influenced metrics I've seen treat
degrade over time even though the
follower accounts are still high it just
seems like less people it just seems
that their viewership counts a little
over time sometimes oftentimes because
they produce content that's locally
relevant to be that's low clear after
the time for example even a lot of
tabloid journalism or a lot of even
people even accuse that accused Gawker
or know people people people even accuse
say The New Yorker being overly
sensationalist because and so that's why
like people like people good people like
Brian Kaplan don't even read the news
and I think that that if you have a
large enough networks that people just
gave the news to you especially in the
Bay Area of course it's still good to be
able still catch you're like I grew up I
think we're in the newspaper and I think
he learned a lot of the world by reading
the news and I think it was good but
once after a certain point you you get
enough intuition for how it works that
you can basically figure out alpha how
to curate period toward to you and more
in a way that captures more of what's
important to you and more relevant
timeless and there's a big difference
between seeing a video show up on your
newsfeed about a specific
company that's maybe doing something
like 3d printing organs versus knowing
the CEO of the company yeah yeah yeah
how do we figure out yeah yes into the
spirit yeah knowing the CEO knowing the
CEO could and so knowing knowing about
3d printing take the phone of Technology
I think no one kind of technology it's
often more times like more important
more timeless but and that's also
transparent someone else is probably
better if this isn't you knowing to CEO
of it it's it's more of a lottery take
it or not look as more than dark boards
sometimes sometimes you just burn out as
most startups they do tend to fail and
most times people tend to act itself to
Austin do you identify the ones that are
going to be there for the long run yeah
yeah those with those people yeah and
also times who are there for the long
run some if it's good to be close to
them early on yeah
and because if you only know them later
on um they yeah that was a Vette ton
brings us back to the point of the
younger that you know someone the more
you know about all the inputs in
opposite went into their life can
persistent influence also have to do
with the way that we reach out to people
that are very high up on the hierarchy
that are inspirational to us that we
want to be persistent with oh yeah well
who write books for example do the
hackers and the influence like sometimes
even if people read books less and less
these days some what happens that people
who do right though it's they are read
by some through preview Tube channels
and eventually their influence is
reached is read by people who create
YouTube channel so like an tree just
like Sara Perry and then and then
presented and then somehow presented out
you a younger generation ala JH yeah
yeah yeah and would you say that every
day that you wake up you're sort of
arrangement of yeah is yeah arrange your
day actually has to maximise knowledge
input it is and I also have to realize
if that's an extent to which I have to
realize that sometimes I can not learn
everything and I will not frustrate you
yes it does frustrate me it frustrates
me too yeah so then so then
that feeling of not being able to know
everything what do ya know today I'm
seeing two more people focus these days
and in fact well a lot of people in the
both past few years they think they see
me primarily people feel because it's
actually it's actually not that I was
always people still feel focused I was
originally more knowledge would say
don't take Clara Ferguson and it turns
people and because when you know people
in the bottom debate you also know this
um people who are just super who are in
resource and you also noticed that
sometimes they're more effective with
their lives and you are locally at the
moment and then you and then from back
you you you figure out how you can be a
better you can be better at say
influencing people in the long run now
you only one person and oftentimes
people who and I'm generalists
oftentimes the unique you have an idea
of how people input output knowledge of
parts knowledge in order to be the most
effective generalists and you have to
basically know how the media works and
know how people without input and output
cycles works which sometimes people
people sometimes good writers especially
those who write after context textbooks
don't exactly those that actually
recognize especially if they especially
if they they they like to be under
evades like you understood by their own
clinical elite group where sometimes you
can actually explode in so many ways if
I can make it actually makes accessible
and to a hue of much wider range of
people so for someone's earliest
formative years yeah what do you
recommend okay so it depends in person
like nah I don't know which one extent
some every child is curious I'm not sure
what percent of the population is
amazing at unspooling themselves they
recently Khurshid Aurora yesterday and
I'll just if you can unscrew it and I
was so freakin amazed at how aggressive
he is and when you when you when you
talk about unsee and explain to be does
that mean a little bit of school does
that mean some high school does that
mean no college is a trial to be on
toxic and should be destroyed I think
college is okay
I'd be destroyed well okay through
kindergarten through eighth grade so on
unpacked that's a very powerful thoughts
yes unpacked why do you think that
because it's very in a flat inflexible
it doesn't allow people to learn what
they're best at it's also very bait it
assumes that the previous that else in
America has it because teachers aren't
smart as people but anyways it's just
like people are aren't just I think
they're so passionate it's like if we do
pretending cuz it's a my favorite
favorite quotes and if I just say the
people just underestimate how much
people can really really learn and
really fast yeah like her she does like
it's speaking amazing and I think why so
the promise the problem of progress
which you can see on the Twitter is that
people up a string coaching tool in
Florida I mean it's just a silly oh if
people are worried about sensitive heart
flowing down and they think the best
which is a true eventually speeding up
scientific progress when they're sick
that's more to learn is that figure out
how to make sure how specialists can can
Correll themselves and chew this
knowledge and thing and just do what
they're really viciously good at and
then doesn't make him awesome and then
but also figure out how they can
communicate the result even even if he
works as fast as possible makes him
communicate themselves in a way that's
reachable to other people I think I know
this super smart guy from Olin - who
recent graduates why's he startup and he
he is super fast and also not the best
at explain it scenes and not the most
patient explained scenes even though
he's seen a starts of trying to explain
how to automate synthetic biology
biologists so how to do this you
basically I mean we're going to have to
Alamut Issyk 23 biologists in a way that
does not slow him down at i really fast
that I for example promise academia is
that we seem the professor's the best
doers are good at explaining things when
they meant them that might bounce it
would be so you just have to capture the
doers doing what they're best at and
just capture as much of what they can
doing at the time and then figure out
someone who's good at explaining
Australian save their the trail to leave
behind for others who or evolve to a
replicator mimic okay so that's really
good okay so K through 12 being
completely abolished
totally okay yeah sure maybe maybe
restructured because what it's doing
right now is just teaching young people
to be obedient workers and not critical
thinkers and people love to have a sense
of control and they don't like to lose a
sense of control they like their
employees to be unpredictable apparently
it seems okay so we take the K through
12 system and we abolish it completely
what do we have then for three year olds
and five year olds what what sort of
system then do we just let them go on
the internet and just think that they're
gonna just go and find whatever
interests them and that's kind of the
process that we think will they'll bet
I'm not sure if that's actually that
much a bad scene the main problem is
they may be attracted to super stimuli
for example drama positive video games
addictive TV especially since a lot of
people seem like world warcraft seems to
be a scheme qpi or dying it's a new game
I find addictions though it's interest
also histidine that's where Kevin ziko
also seemed to be deep in influence over
time like they're not popular they used
to be e so what exactly is it they can
it's probably related socially through a
lot of validation seekers and often and
I think I think we should also just
touch on the fact that you said that
college though it's totally fine to keep
because there's a couple reasons yeah I
think maybe and tell me if I'm right
here first of all is the professors that
are there are actually really
world-class yes they are really good I'm
also you you do gather a huge amount of
smart people into those clusters and
interesting things happens in these
clusters of smart people yeah and then
also it's kind of the proper once by the
time year whatever 14 or 16 or 18 when
you can enter this College let's say
then you will have already done a pretty
good amount of identifying what you care
about then you can go into that sort of
yeah like for example her she and she
changed her mind about going to college
like even though he's unschool yourself
and right now I'm being [ __ ] amazing
at just Exeter on projects I figured
like what he does she
shoutout to Harshita by the way she
she's your friend that you and Matt
morass the back who is all who we've
also had on the show have recommended us
to have on the show and we were now
coordinating to have her on the show
she's currently programming the ability
to wear an EEG over your head and be
able to think the way that a drone flies
and think fly left think she's me yes
yeah that is something that's nothing
that no one teaches about even though
it's it's like the most important
problem because she's teaching herself
how to do this process yeah a lot of
people are teaching himself how to do it
and of course because he works eval you
can see here we also have a lot of
babblers who also trying to seek you
think what I'm trying to weaken told
Syncopators and actually are it's
important to develop a system that's
discourages people from being babblers
and but without but what other services
I'm true to aggressively ask questions
and admit where they're weak or wrong
and maybe figure out if and also given
feedback about whether or not they're
approaching that it seems that in the
right direction because not everyone is
equally good at every scene and for my
practicum I try to learn everything
first and even though many I am a speedy
learned what I'm really good at I
originally learned of the wrong topics
which it didn't with which wasn't the
fastest of learning even even though I
just learned see the internet and a lot
of a lot of super fast rates and alpha
but about you of agent as well it's
super fast rate okay let's talk about
risk-taking and comfort zone yeah yeah
are you - are you typically on the on
the thought of just shattering through
uncomfortability and just being as
uncomfortable what it looks different
for every person
sometimes some what is risk-taking just
going out there comfort zone because
sometimes people prefer to be in the
comfort zone all the time and sometimes
dressmaking just means breaking a habit
even just doing something uncomfortable
even though it might not not objectively
might not not even being at risk but
maybe
cognitively it's perceived as a risk and
it's just imagine to bring this risk
anyways I know a coordinate of a
coordination problem I know some people
like some good people like Martin Nowak
are in the problems coordination because
I think right now oh we do have a few of
the cordons you probably
trust themselves of other people and
maybe when people don't to make
everything no and maybe when people
preference change over time maybe people
like maybe people still I think school
also encourage yourself interest because
they all make people want recurring
theme so I see PA but sometimes if you
opt off for happiness sometimes you
realize that sometimes it is
Thank You Ronnie that's our 15 minutes
so if you often feel happiness sometimes
your life and happiness is oftentimes
through making to other people around
you more most effect it's the most the
problem of course in the school pairs
you up with a bunch of people who you're
not necessarily the best fit with and
sometimes making them the happiest it's
not exactly the thing that makes you the
happiest you figuring out who makes you
happiest is a long coordination game but
making sure you you pair up with people
you are most long-term value language
and know he knows a prep Lanka
preferences like this is why I think the
teal culture was such one of the most
important themes to happen in the last
ten years by far because it just created
a new a totally new a different
incentive structure prestige structure
and I'll push for unschooling yes yes
exactly it's flipping the norm normal
system is and if you are like
coordination problems in some of the
rationally community views a lot with
people often say that trying to get
rationalist into a coordination problems
like herding cats
perhaps because rationalist tend to be
people of the describe rationalist as
high openness low conscientiousness
because sometimes they are they can't
you like Wikipedia topics clue
explosions sometimes a lot of references
were awesome emotion traumatized a
school because they were there good
enough at it you could do well but then
something happens and they'd that
screwed them over afterwards and then
they don't know what you do something
they still continue with objective
knowledge of objectives frontier I'm
trying to maximize knowledge even though
they're not even sure where it leaves
them and there are kids inside with
knowing the right things you learn but
on the other hand it don't know that you
don't really only can learn all of world
history no there should be the most
effective person for for your goals
whatever your long-term goals are which
may be you know eat ammonia
many people in long run coordination
problems also be around the everything
from trying to figure out how to build
yeah yeah identical but also
coordinating how do together as a planet
a lot of people I know do you ever
example of this you one of the things
that I find interesting is why for
example MIT and Harvard students tend to
go to grad school at lower rates than
say people students from liberal arts
called you colleges or you Chicago or
Caltech or read and sometimes people
think a liberal arts colleges like to
advertise themselves as being good in
that front but a lot of times grass
Butte that students don't have the best
life outcomes after college after
college after college and this could be
the and there are and if there are many
people who debate over whether or not
that's good or bad I do believe in
general then it's good you have more
knowledge workers and we should have
more funding and support for science but
on the other hand we need more supports
we just really need more kind of
supports are expendable
Loret de Maynes den means twitter seems
to capture much of the site case of
what's wrong of what's important what's
wrong with the world today and one
important tweet cheaper to get out was
on academia is the complete for academia
is and Sarris out suggestions like
academia is killing my friends academic
is dead academic academia is broken and
it seems like there's a like a consent
problem with it was in academia where
people are people contend you become
graduates it was out exactly knowledge
of what wouldn't else only what and what
their real objective functions are
afterwards especially because they grew
of grew up on the validation function
that being a better student produces
better result in general yeah okay
how about we talk a bit about
rationality on the way out yeah yeah and
send me this centreford applied
rationality there's this amazing group
of people that you were just hanging out
with and so so what is why are you so
passionate about rationality I I know
many of the best people I know distance
themselves nationally because of the
types of people it's attractive
therefore they label themselves post
rationalists but I still think rationale
in general is I mean I said I it's
generally good seeing true practice as
long as you embrace for tennis for
example the tenets of rationality such
other tenants such as you should avoid
magical sinking we should always seek
out harsh truths earlier Rosen later you
should also I'm sorry you should also be
prepared to reconfigure your ballot
function around more of what you are and
what what you can't change rather things
you could not change and yeah all the
other things that a lot of these people
but in terms of what bleating what's
popping within puffle other people don't
really really do not believe with
possible for example there this one
person who's become a legend Stanford
club party and actually from Iran and
she is surprised everyone I'm she
original wasn't on techno but she
somehow I was through interacting with a
huge shitload of really smart people is
like because looting the Shannon labs on
project which it basically raised funds
from and then people true to basically
so this is the thing I've noticed that a
lot of people are raising new funding
for example Laura Demi is also like or
even kind of your fund and young
promising people and then another person
and then even though I also knows it's
that leverage has attracted a lot of
funding from people like teal in order
to figure out how to maximize to the
extreme right end and the extreme right
end is might be a collection of
personalities now what seeing people
oftentimes associate a successful is GE
and or and one thing was people on the
extreme right and they often on time
probably uneven what people what do you
mean cognitively I believe in me that
they're visually good at some scenes but
they're not as good as other people you
often observe this and people who win
international map Olympia's or like
people of like great at math but not
great at social skills yeah there's a
longer story behind this ami harmony
where the book of others later but it's
not as though stolen skills it's just
because they spend so much time over
pepper for the contest that really they
become better over prepare for the
contest but then they lose life
experience other types a lot expands
notice
growing up okay Alex I want to make sure
that we target this because this is
something that we talked about and I
thought was a really important you have
now told me that you what do you think
is now the most beautiful thing in the
world I thought this was really
important to to share I will blow the
connections all the connections and
information and neurons and synapses
it's not tonight batons and enter enter
and pairwise interaction no distance
entered boot excellent paternal distance
people and and say the and say did you
do like a PPO arrangement people's near
onset like reduce memory and people
produce produce a person's input outfits
hit a person and alter what all of us
just everything they're just exposed to
it's just so amazing and you can access
it in so many ways and it's just so
beautiful and it's just like for example
there are certain have athletic or just
attracted true to just what's wonderful
and what's amazing the world and then
maybe they and just have a strong game I
thought it and yes if they know what
they remember really well it's just
intense that what they're what they can
basically teach other people yeah okay
then the sort of most beautiful thing is
the way that when a mind is birthed into
the world just absorbs inputs and how
that mind forms over time over a year
developmental history the development of
history the developmental history
developmental history of a mind as well
as of all minds as well
so mostly beautiful seeing there many
deafness have seen I think just of
particular minds especially the minds of
people who have particularly strong cast
at a aesthetic and who are not prevented
from exploring every and who are just so
left so free and who just have such such
strong drives who does continue being a
maven unconstrained I think I'm very
blessed I think we're very blessed and
know you and your insatiable appetite
for knowledge yeah
just still miss targeted at the
beginning and I just want wish that its
feature Minds would not be somewhat
targeted yeah okay have you thought more
about simulation have what what yeah
what do you what is your take on not
only simulation theory but also just in
general kind of what knowledge that can
give us thinking about it
simulation series so I know there are
ways to stimulate converting visual
representations one team to another
scene what about top type
representations give an environment
entire in pedestrian I don't know we
can't treat there are so many people who
create simulations of simple systems
like no climate systems and the question
is and often people like dicing question
not whether or not they actually produce
results that are that are forgettable
that are actually they say legitimate
enough but the problem and that's not
sometimes unless you the insight they
give new mental models in which people
can operate and stuff because people sin
has learned better through mental models
or because often would you create
simulations an expected behavior so
insight insight is basically for example
insight is various ways of cause and
effects that could trigger that could be
a recurring relevance of occurring
relevance that can basically the problem
is that sometimes people over at Astraea
simulations especially they if they're
not the most curious open-minded in
which case you may be over attached to
Chua simulations and they think
simulations are a clue the reasonable to
use as long as you constantly hedge them
and do you think that this is base
reality or that you are playing a role
playing game right now oh god the world
is so weird what do you think's the
weirdest thing about the world
everything I heard that you made me melt
a little world no sense collectively
anyway damn that yeah that feeling such
a strange place
do you think we're not so beautiful
that's all it isn't why don't you die
you're a beautiful person Alex yeah how
do you how do you balance the beauty of
the world with the weirdness of the
world your weirdness is part of the
beauty in a way but who knows it's so
sensitive and I use drugs to be careful
I mean I thank you I know
ah we must have that we must have the
confidence to know what do you have our
own confidence and proper say not a
presentation the epidemics to not mess
it up in favor of some stupid objective
function that relies and feeling the one
is better than other people which is
basically the objective function logical
still rely on and I think a lot of
people can rely on directive functions
that have transcended all yet to
transcend the feeling that one half
people are better than other people you
have to be better than other if you feel
good about yourself yeah yeah and you're
right it's such a delicate place that it
can easily just go yeah yeah Alex Wow
and also feeling no control over power
and we also have we control we have who
we define with control and power really
meaning other people hold on to the idea
that they need that happens again happen
some control they feel like they need to
be continually in control over other
people in order for their world to still
remain the same or for them to afford
scenes to evolve in the way they want
you when in reality they don't
necessarily need to be in control all
the time the way than the way they want
you but it still needs like coordinate
we still need to figure out the
coordination problem and the way that if
explainable try to in a way that they as
they ideally want to be explained
we are so grateful to have had this
conversation with you Alex I want to
mention how insanely interesting it was
that you reminded me a lot of the debate
days because you were speaking at a very
quick pace which enabled you to get out
a lot of information in a little bit of
time that we have so and I think that's
very interesting because sometimes
people will speak slow or medium pace
but you went really fast which was able
to just get out a tremendous amount of
information you can also any readers
Watchers can density 0.55 to speed
yeah for anybody that thought that Alex
is speaking quite quickly you can
definitely point seven five percent the
speed three fourths the speed of the
video or if you thought he was being too
slowly you can also knowing smart people
well and knowing what they need can also
allow would you be like an ideal
personal assistant to them level just
know that just know where and just know
yes and then they will value and then
you will basically mirror and adopt many
of those people effective happens even
if you're not necessarily the smartest
person yourself yes and this is a
frequent thing of the people that come
on to our program is that we know
nothing about neuroscience but we'll
have someone that does study
neuroscience their whole life so we'll
try and provide them with some sort of
value uh and they'll be like oh thank
you yeah I don't know about that or this
and then we'll slowly take into our
being more of what they know about
neuroscience and and it gives us a
better general and understanding of that
and more all right Alex this has been
such a pleasure getting to know you
better and getting to know about these
interesting things that happen around
you and we're we talked about so many
interesting things generalist specialist
organization of knowledge persistent
influence rationality coordination
problems comfort zones
it was super fun I still find it
fascinating that you want to overhaul
the whole k-12 system I think that we
can figure out a much better way to
school it is no small problem because
the youngest minds and the most
neoplastic they have the high school
intelligence and they often have the
highest energy levels and you need
levels see crisis because ages and food
intelligence does and
and it was a miss of the most effective
or in their forties but in reality the
thousand that's it and that's an
artifact of just how longer training
people look at Michael nuisance quit
Twitter about how an H parameter needs
odor or People v weight power and
authority just works but it didn't
really have to be that way it's only
because even though one Singh was a lot
of smart suppose it allows Marcus aren't
even the most self-aware and I noticed
this because I know a lot of people who
know people in the top universities who
notice that they they're not the most
self-aware but you can athlete but
sometimes you can trigger them to bow
themself awareness more and more so much
love for what you care about thank you
very much for coming out to the show
again out yeah such a pleasure to have
you I'm really looking forward to the
next episode together whether you're in
the barrier we can't have to Boston
looking forward to it Kelly yeah looking
forward to to to talking to more about
what we're writing about working about
really and it's a time in neural
infrastructure so there's a lot of
interesting collapse there much love
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
if you guys had a good time
check out alex's work below also give us
a comment let us know your thoughts
let's have some conversation the
community about all these topics we
discussed you guys know don't just
consume this content go create with it
go and make videos go make blogs go
start companies go do [ __ ] with this
also subscribe during the family join us
on patreon help support us so we can go
and scale this content and go and impact
more people with it and fill sports
stadiums much love everyone thanks for
tuning in thanks to our team Ron mark
Alfredo much love everyone peace
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]